hey David seriously what is wrong with
compulsive liars like Trump in real life
and other people that I know in real
life is it a medical condition so
there's actually quite a bit of literate
literature about this pathological or
compulsive lying is a condition that is
named and you know that doesn't tell us
anything about it one way or the other
you can argue that we have over
medicalization in our society were
things that should not really be
diagnoseable conditions are diagnoseable
conditions but there is a condition
called pathological lying it's the
behavior of habitual or compulsive lying
some psychiatrists distinguish
pathological lying and compulsive lying
others say that it's the same thing but
the idea is that there is a
medicalization of this phenomena which
not everybody necessarily agrees with
it's a standalone disorder it is often
also a symptom of other conditions like
psychopathy and antisocial personality
disorder often will have compulsive or
pathological lying narcissists often lie
compulsively people with histrionic
Personality Disorder often will have
pathological or compulsive lying
the average onset is 16 years and for
people who have above-average
intelligence at least average or
above-average they tend to be more
likely to develop this condition of
pathological or compulsive lying now if
we want to reject for a second that this
is merely a something to medicalize name
and then look at which pill can deal
with it I've dealt with a lot of
compulsive liars in my life I've told
some of these stories before in high
school I worked with people who were
compulsive liars and they would lie
about things much like Trump actually
were you wonder why would you lie about
something number one so insignificant
and number two so easily falsifiable I
vividly remember a girl that I knew who
said that she had you know $600 glasses
or something like that and at the time I
remember thinking I know that you don't
I know that you know at the time based
on what things cost at the
nobody our age has $600 glasses your
glasses clearly aren't special there are
normal glasses from the place down the
street but I didn't really understand
what it was about that that was
appealing to her why was it appealing to
lie and claimed that she had $600
glasses and it probably connected to
some insufficiency that she fell
elsewhere which she was trying to make
up for with the totally false notion
that she owned this really expensive
thing that maybe people would find
interesting I my reaction when I meet
compulsive liars and I've met a lot of
them is I don't even react with any kind
of surprise to the lies they tell
because what I've sort of learned from
experience is that oftentimes the
compulsive liar is looking to generate a
reaction and they feed off of that
reaction and they notice that when they
tell these lies a lot of other people
will react and they will become more
interested in the person or they will
react visibly in a way that sort of
fuels the person's desire to tell more
of these stories so I've dealt with
people who say yeah it's actually yeah I
mean I just can't even think now but
there's so many examples I just got back
from a trip they actually got brought
over to Japan I just spent two weeks
there because I go over there and do
speeches and they they pay me 50 grand a
speech and it's really great and I know
that the person has no money and I know
that they can barely afford rent and I
know that they were asking another
friend of mine whether they could maybe
move in together
I don't even react like I'm impressed I
say wow that's really great that's
interesting and then I just move on to
something else that actually interests
me and this will often what really
happens is the person just stops being
interested in talking to me because I'm
not giving them the the feedback that
they want so that's my experience I find
the compulsive lying very toxic although
I am completely open to the idea that it
connects to childhood trauma or other
conditions or whatever I'm not saying
compulsive liars or bad people or
anything like that but for me for the
way I like to live my life and the
people I like to be around I just ignore
the line completely pretend like
everything is not only true that they're
saying but so unremarkable that it's
like if they said I bought I bought a
bananas this morning oh wow that's
interesting
yeah that's it I'm going to move on to
something that's interesting
me and typically they will distance
themselves because they want to be
around people who will react in the way
that they like that feeds the lying and
often gets them to tell more lies
let me know your experiences with
compulsive or pathological liars
interested to hear your take we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the world-famous
bonus show